[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin einen schönen freitagabend
ihnen allen christian otto unter anderem
mit dem blick auf ekstase bei andrea
franke und die enttäuschung bei leipzig
genannt das haben wir heute für sie
vorbereitet
deutsche panzerhaubitzen für kiew schon
nächste woche will berlin ukrainische
soldaten dafür ausbilden
umkämpftes symbol das stahlwerk in
mariupol ist weiter unter beschuss
offenbar gibt es vorbereitungen für eine
sieges parade in der stadt
und wilde eintracht party frankfurts
kicker stürmen ins europa league finale
und die fans den rasen
okra ines präsident wird konkreter und
lädt den bundeskanzler für den neunten
mai nach kiew ein am tag zuvor plant
olaf scholz eine tv ansprache zur
ukraine krieg und dem ende des zweiten
weltkriegs lange hatte sich der kanzler
ja mit der lieferung schwerer waffen an
die ukraine schwer getan dann stellte
die bundesregierung gepa panzer in
aussicht seit heute ist klar dabei wird
es nicht bleiben
sieben panzerhaubitzen 2000 aus
bundeswehr beständen sollen der ukraine
zur verfügung gestellt werden das sind
schwere artilleriekanonen auf
kettenfahrzeugen bis zu 40 kilometer
weit können sie schießen und so den
eigenen truppen auch aus der entfernung
helfen mehr von mathis feldhoff
jetzt wird sie doch geliefert wochenlang
hatte die bundesregierung argumentiert
die panzerhaubitze 2000 sei zu
kompliziert die bundeswehr könne auf
keines ihrer exemplare verzichten nach
der ankündigung der niederlande geraten
verteidigungsministerin und kanzler
unter zugzwang
das was vor wochen unmöglich war geht
ganz plötzlich deswegen wird es ab
nächster woche die ausbildung geben in
deutschland an dieser waffe an dieser
panzerhaubitze und danach werden
insgesamt zwölf von vollendeter systeme
sieben deutsche systeme die ukraine in
diesem mutigen kampf unterstützt
die panzerhaubitze gilt als modernste
waffe ihrer art eine gebündelte
schussabgabe führt zur größtmöglichen
wirkung und das auf weite entfernung
die niederlande haben vorgelegt haben
entschieden panzerhaubitzen zur
verfügung zu stellen dadurch dass
bundeskanzler scholz unter druck geraten
hat jetzt spät entschieden wir sind mal
wieder letzter das ist schade in der
praxis stocken die schweren
waffenlieferungen aber für den flug
panzer gepard sucht die bundesregierung
weltweit nach munition und die
instandsetzung der seit zehn jahren
ausgemusterten panzer kann noch monate
dauern
versprechen alleine aber sind zu wenig
so der ukrainische botschafter alleine
bei den zusagen die gemacht wurden
stichwort gebaut flac panzer ich kann
ihnen berichten dass es keinen
millimeter fortschritte gegeben hat und
auch der ringtausch etwa mit slowenien
die alte t-72 in die ukraine liefern und
dafür moderne waffen aus deutschland als
ersatz erwarten gestalten sich schwierig
der angebotene 50 jahre alte maler
erscheint den slowenen nicht adäquat
dort will man lieber den modernen
schützenpanzer puma nun sucht man nach
einem kompromiss
nun heißt es ja russlands präsident
wolle seinem volk zum tag des sieges
über nazi deutschland am 9 mai auch die
einnahme des stahlwerks von mario käufer
könnten ob es dazu kommt das ist offen
noch harren die verteidiger jedenfalls
dort aus und nach britischen
geheimdienste informationen hat das
russische militär in mariupol
empfindliche verluste erlitten mehr von
volker dutschek
die bilder gleichen sich seit tagen das
zusammengeschlossene stahlwerk dankt
unter den bomben der russen aber es
steht noch und solange er steht es ist
ein symbol der hoffnung für die ukraine
und ihre unterstützer im westen für
putin könnte es zum symbol des
scheiterns werden deswegen will er
schnell aus der welt haben das weiß auch
präsident sie lenski und beschwört die
weltöffentlichkeit
wir müssen die zivilisten noch rausholen
frauen kinder viele kinder sind noch da
stellen sie sich diese hölle vor mehr
als zwei monate ständiger beschuss
bombenangriffe der ständige tod um sie
herum
amnesty international spricht von
beweisen für kriegsverbrechen durch
russland und will weitere fälle
dokumentieren das leben im versteck und
die flucht im auffanglager sapori cia
230 kilometer von mario pohl entfernt
haben viele traumatische erfahrung
spätfolgen nicht ausgeschlossen
die ganze zeit haben sie bomben
abgeworfen brandbomben die einfach alles
zerstört haben
die kinder sind mit den nerven fertig
beim kleinsten geräusch laufen sie weg
mario pohl soll herausgeputzt werden
aber es sind nur kosmetische korrekturen
in einer stark zerstörten stadt
pro-russische helfer und besatzer packen
mit an für montag zum gedenken an das
ende des zweiten weltkrieges werden
schon mal die russischen fahnen gehisst
eine für den kriegsverlauf besonders
wichtige statistin nikolajew im süden
fast seit beginn der russischen invasion
wird dort gekämpft und noch ist die
stadt unter kontrolle der ukraine aber
vom besetzten herz von aus versuchen
russische truppen vorzustoßen nur über
mikoleit kämen sie bis zur
millionenstadt und besser und könnten so
die gesamte ukrainische schwarzmeerküste
besetzen unser reporter dara hassanzadeh
war in nikolassee von berichtet vom
leben unter ständigem beschuss nicolai
es das verwaltungsgebäude des
gouverneurs es wurde ende märz durch
eine russische rakete zerstört 36
menschen starben
jetzt anfang mai hat sich die lage für
die menschen weiter verschlechtert die
russische armee hat die wasserrohre
gesprengt wohl wissen dass sie dadurch
250.000 zivilisten von sauberem
trinkwasser
abschneidet wir hatten ein normales
leben wir hatten alles von was uns die
russen befreien wollen wir verstehen das
bis heute nicht
es regnet manchmal dann sammeln wir das
regenwasser und bewahren es in unserer
badewanne auf man gewöhnt sich auch
daran
dazu kommt fast täglicher beschuss
gefahr verbreiten nicht nur die raketen
die explodieren sondern auch die
blindgänger das bombenentschärfung steam
wurde von anwohnern gerufen der
sprengsatz ist noch nicht vollständig
explodiert eine gezielte sprengung
mitten im wohngebiet
nikolov ist von besonderer strategischer
bedeutung
nikolov ist äußerst wichtig für uns von
hier ist ein vorstoß aus süden auf
unserer hauptstadt kiew möglich und man
kann von hier aus und besser erobern um
dann unser land vollständig vom export
übers meer abzuschneiden vor dem krieg
galt die bevölkerung in nikolaev als in
teilen russlandfreundlich davon ist wohl
nichts mehr geblieben
zu corona die gefahr durch das virus ist
laut robert-koch-institut immer noch
hoch aber nicht mehr sehr hoch das lka
hat seine risikobewertung um eine stufe
zurück genommen weil die zahlen besser
werden nicht nur die erfassten
infektionen auch die belegung der
intensivstationen und die todesfälle
sind zuletzt zurückgegangen dennoch sei
vorsicht weiter wichtig mahnt das rk ii
und empfiehlt weiter abstand halten und
maske tragen
mit spannung schaut die bundespolitik
auf die nächsten zwei wahlsonntag klar
das ist ein stimmungstest für berlin
wenn am 15 mai in nordrhein-westfalen
und jetzt am sonntag in schleswig
holstein gewählt wird und dorthin
schauen wir zuerst bemerkenswert viele
sind laut politbarometer noch unsicher
ob und wen sie wählen wenn schon jetzt
gewählt würde käme die cdu auf 38
prozent die spd auf 18 ebenso die grünen
die fdp auf 8 die afg auf 6 und der
südschleswigsche wählerverband auf 6
prozent bei der frage wie man lieber als
regierungschef beziehungsweise chefin in
schleswig-holstein hätte liegt
ministerpräsident günther sehr deutlich
mit 64 prozent vor seinen
herausforderern mehr von hannah
hebestreit
ministerpräsident daniel günther von der
cdu geht mit breiter brust in die
letzten stunden des wahlkampfs
rechtzeitig von corona genesen kämpfte
für die fortsetzung seines kurses ist
dabei aber in sorge dass seine anhänger
die wahl schon für gewonnen hatten es
ist immer noch denkbar knapp denn
natürlich müssen wir auch dafür sorgen
dass keine regierung gegen uns gebildet
werden kann und der möchte dass die cdu
weiterregiert in schleswig-holstein wer
möchte dass ich ministerpräsident bleibe
muss eben auch wissen dass am sonntag
dann die stimmabgabe zählt nach der wahl
dürfte im kieler landtag schluss sein
mit der im norden durchaus populären
jamaika-koalition nach umfragen könnte
die cdu günthers mit nur einem
koalitionspartner auskommen im gerangel
um platz zwei setzt die grüne konkurrenz
deshalb auf hilfe von vizekanzler
menschen in regierungsverantwortung will
der muss grün wählen es gibt kein
jamaika kreuz die grüne stimme für
soziale gerechtigkeit für klimaschutz
zählt von der berliner regierungs
prominenz erhofft sich auch
spd-spitzenkandidat thomas loster müller
unterstützung auf den letzten metern mit
dem kanzler im rücken setzte auf die
stimmen der vielen unentschlossenen
jeder dritte wird erst am sonntag
entscheiden wie sie sich bei was sie
wählen wollen was für eine regierung sie
haben wollen das angebot der spd ist
klar wer möchte dass dieses land sozial
regiert wird muss die spd wählen
fdp-spitzenkandidat buchholz will morgen
ein letztes ausrufezeichen im wahlkampf
setzen dann gemeinsam mit fdp-chef
lindner buchholz will an der seite der
cdu erneut in die regierung kommen die
bürgerinnen und bürger haben jetzt diese
wunderbare chance wenn wir da jamaika zu
bestätigen wenn das ergebnis so ist oder
sie müssen einen der partner auswählen
wer dann tatsächlich auch mit daniel
winter gemeinsam reagieren
entschieden hat die fdp dass sie eine
ampel mit grünen und der spd im kieler
landtag ausschließt sollte der vorsprung
der union tatsächlich so groß werden wie
prognostiziert
sicher dürfte die vertretung der
dänischen minderheit ins parlament
einziehen von der fünf prozent hürde ist
der ssw ja befreit letzte umfragen
machen auch der afg hoffnung auf
rückkehr in den landtag trotz massiver
parteiinterne auseinandersetzungen auch
hier im norden selbst wenn der sieger
der wahl nach umfragen festzustehen
scheint die parteien ringen im
wahlkampf-endspurt und gute
ausgangsposition mit den folgenden
machtpoker an der kieler förde
und von schleswig holstein nach
nordrhein westfalen wo die ausgangslage
gut eine woche vor der wahl komplett
anders ist denn hier liegen cdu und spd
fast kopf an kopf wenn schon am nächsten
sonntag gewählt würde käme die cdu
zurzeit auf 30 prozent die spd auf
28 die fdp auf 7 ebenso die afd die
grünen gewinnen an zustimmung sie liegen
bei 18 prozent und die linke bei drei
prozent das mögliche plus bei den grünen
könnte am ende ausschlaggebend für die
regierungsbildung seien dort fr
berichtet grüner wahlkampf in bochum
mitten im ruhrgebiet
spitzenkandidatin mona neubaur wird für
neue energie im alten kohlerevier wenn
es nach uns grünen geht dann ist das für
die zukunft die kraft von sonne und wind
energiewende verkehrswende die themen
der grünen und nach den umfragen geht
regieren künftig nur mit grün ob aber
schwarz grün rot grün oder ein
dreierbündnis das ist völlig offen ich
glaube die letzten wahlen haben uns
gezeigt dass man fehler macht wenn man
sagte das geht und das geht nicht
entscheidend wird sein dass die richtung
der nächsten regierung stimmt und dafür
braucht es starke grüne
die fdp schwächelt laut umfragen reicht
es nicht mehr für schwarz gelb wie
bislang
spitzenkandidat joachim stammt aber
könnte in einem dreierbündnis dabei sein
ja als politik eine gesamt verantwortung
gegenüber den bürgerinnen und
wirtschafts und bildungspolitik die fdp
themen ihre schulpolitik in pandemie
zeiten umstritten das schwächt die
partei dennoch könnte die fdp bei
regierungsbildung entscheidend sein bei
einer jamaika oder eine ampelkoalition
alle demokratischen parteien schließen
keine koalition untereinander aus das
entscheiden am ende die wählerinnen und
wähler aber für uns ist es wichtig dass
es keine koalition gibt wo die grüne
alleine mit einem partner unterwegs und
ich glaube dass wir fürs land ich gut
wer zieht hier in den landtag ein wer
regiert nordrhein westfalen das ist
offen 40 prozent der wähler sind noch
unentschieden
schauen wir zur csu der vakante posten
des generalsekretärs ist von parteichef
söder neu besetzt worden um mit ihm
hatten die wenigsten gerechnet martin
huber heißt der neue ein echter
überraschungskandidat der 44 jährige
promovierte politikwissenschaftler kommt
wie sein vorgänger aus dem landkreis
altötting
sitz seit 2013 im bayerischen landtag
und sei jung modern konservativ so söder
und auch seriös der bisherige
generalsekretär mayer ist am dienstag
zurückgetreten
die party affäre des britischen premiers
johnson hat offenbar auch beim wahlvolks
spuren hinterlassen bei den kommunal und
regionalwahlen verloren seine
konservativen tories diverse langjährige
hochburgen was den druck auf johnson aus
der eigenen partei weiter erhöhen dürfte
yasin herrlein über einen angeschlagenen
premier und eine labour opposition die
wieder hoffen kann
eine trophäe mit symbolwert nennt man
das was sich die oppositionelle
labour-partei da im londoner stadtteil
wandsworth geholt hat 44 jahre lang
regierten hier die konservativen auch
investment start labour die tories
überholt hier und den anderen
landesteilen bleibt ab gewählten
gemeinderäten jetzt nur technisch den
obersten dienstherrn der konservativen
partei die schuld zu geben
es war party geht und alles was damit
zusammenhängt es geht hier um integrität
die leute glauben nicht dass sie sich
noch darauf verlassen können dass der
premierminister ihnen die wahrheit sagt
doch nicht nur der skandal um illegales
feiern in der downing street zu lockern
zeiten hat dazu geführt dass labour vor
allem in der hauptstadt ordentlich
zugelegt hat bekochte die gestiegenen
lebenshaltungskosten und die massiven
sparmaßnahmen der konservativen haben
die leute beschäftigt und boris johnson
selbst hat uns stimmen eingebracht als
damen natürlich auch
hat letzterer der oppositionsführer von
der labour-partei genug grund und mut zu
fassen die konservativen bei den
nächsten parlamentswahlen zu gefährden
das bild außerhalb londons ist nämlich
eher gemischt was unter anderem auch an
den zugewinnen der grünen und vor allem
der liberaldemokraten in ländlichen
gegenden liegt
der premierminister heute bei einem
schulbesuch räumt ein es sei eine harte
wahlnacht gewesen die niederlage scheint
vielen tories aber nicht heftig genug um
sich sogleich gegen johnson zu wenden
oder sich bei weiteren entwicklungen im
party geht skandal jedoch sehr rasch
ändern könnte
die allermeisten freuen sich gerade über
feines frühlingswetter ganz anders im
süden nach starken regenfällen und
überschwemmungen in oberbayern ist ein
mensch ums leben gekommen es handelt
sich nach feuerwehrangaben um den fahrer
dieses kleintransporters
das unglück ereignete sich in einer
unterführung dort hatte sich das wasser
gesammelt und war bis auf acht meter
angestiegen eine autofahrerin konnte in
letzter minute gerettet werden heute
abend könnte es südlich der donau zu
weiteren regenfällen kommen
ja ich lag falsch mit dem deutschen
finale in der europa league bleibt sich
jetzt raus aber die eintracht ist
ausgerastet ausgerastet ist genau
richtig pure euphorie glücksgefühle
eintracht frankfurt hat nach 42 jahren
wieder ein finale auf einer europäischen
fußball-bühne erreicht ungeschlagen bis
ins endspiel 1 0 gegen west ham united
four wahrlich beeindruckende kulisse für
die es nach abpfiff kein halten gab
einen platzsturm wie den der eintracht
fans nach schlusspfiff hat die uefa
schon mal mit einer geldstrafe geahndet
doch die euphorie bricht sich nunmal
bahn nach dem 1 0 gegen west ham durch
das tor von raphael poirée in der 26
minute
das schönste wenn man dann eine freude
machen kann und die wollten sie einfach
mit uns teilen also es war in keinster
form irgendeine aggressivität auf dem
platz danach weist 1 travel sieht rot
die eintracht ist mehr als eine stunde
in überzahl doch nur ein dicker muss mal
den ausgleich verhindern das war alles
gemeistert
[Musik]
die fans im stadion tun so als wäre der
titel schon da aber soweit ist es noch
nicht
tja vielleicht aber haben 18 mai in
silvia dort wäre auch gern eher beleibt
sich frankfurts gegner gewesen aber es
reichte nicht 13 bei den glasgow rangers
die große chance auf das erste
europapokal finale der club geschichte
wurde nicht genutzt
tief enttäuschte sachsen überglückliche
schotten im hexenkessel einbruchs park
verabschiedet sich leipzig von seinen
titelträumen in der europa league das
aber ziemlich unnötig die rangers mit
doppelschlag in der 18 minute durch
carney und in der 24 durch kamera aber
ein tor wird in sachsen schon reichen
für die verlängerung und das team von
domenico tedesco kommt zurück ins spiel
und konko 70 der anschlusstreffer aber
dann passen die sachsen noch einmal
entscheiden 3 zu 1 glas burgen finale
leipzig drauf geschenken gegentore zu
leicht her haben in den letzten spielen
die stabilität verloren und die gilt es
ganz ganz schnell wieder
zurückzugewinnen dennoch geht es für
leipzig und was in der saison im
nationalen pokal finale wartet freiburg
morgen in zwei wochen in berlin danke
christin und zum schluss noch eine
mission die man kann es nicht anders
sagen erfolgreich ins wasser gefallen
ist zumindest zum schluss eine dragon
kapsel mit dem deutschen astronauten
maurer und drei us kollegen an bord
landete heute morgen planmäßig vor der
küste floridas im meer fast ein halbes
jahr war maurer an bord der raumstation
iss und auch zur stunde hat er im grunde
keinen festen boden unter den füßen er
sitzt nämlich noch im flieger nach
deutschland
noch zum wetter morgen eher durchwachsen
sonntag deutlich sonniger mehr gleich
von katja horneffer wir empfehlen um 22
uhr des heute journal mit christian
sievers schlittern so langsam ins
wochenende jetzt sagen schönen dank für
das interesse und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend während sich der nebel hier
im laufe des tages auflöste wollen
gleichzeitig im nordosten deutschlands
quellwolken in den himmel außerdem gibt
es ja auch dichtere wolken die von der
nordsee herankommen und unter diesen
wolken verbirgt sich eine kaltfront die
bringt regen mit und das merken wir
schon heute nacht an der nordseeküste
sonst ist es zum teil auch mal klar in
süddeutschland allerdings bleibt immer
noch bei den regenschauern die
temperaturen sinken auf werte zwischen
11 grad und niederrhein und 4 grad zb
hier in sachsen die höchsttemperaturen
morgen liegen zwischen 19 und 24 grad
nur direkt am alpenrand und an den
küsten verlockend osten bleibt es kühler
mit 14 bis 18 grad in norddeutschland
liegt das daran dass dann ja die
kaltfront durchgezogen sein wird dann
lockern die wolken nachmittags mit
nordwestwind auf die kaltfront league
morgen mittag etwa zwischen der usa und
dem rhein da gibt es regenschauer und
gewitter da zeigt sich zwischendurch
aber auch mal die sonne deutlich
sonniger ist es morgen hier in baden
württemberg südlich der donau aber
machen sie sich weiterhin auf
regenschauer und gewitter gefasst die
werden sich am sonntag dann immer mehr
richtung süden zurück ziehen einzelne
schauer gibt es noch in den
mittelgebirgen sonst aber wird es ein
sehr sonniger muttertag guten abend